how did Boeing get so bad well usually  with these sorts of things there's never  a singular reason but one large Catalyst  that many Aviation experts point to it  is the McDonald Douglas acquisition in  1997. before this acquisition Boeing was  largely filled with engineers in fact  people often described a bowling as an  Association of Engineers as opposed to  an actual company obviously Boeing  themselves were slowly shifting away  from this by the late 1990s but mdia  aggressively accelerated this transition  you see it MD was the exact opposite of  Boeing they had a reputation of cutting  corners and maximizing profits over  everything else considering this I don't  know why Boeing decided to even acquire  them but they did it and almost  immediately you could see the effect